they say you can't fight city hall but
if you don't fight the government you're
you're done because they're not right
what they're doing to us is not right
I'm a rancher in north central Nevada
we're bred and born Nevada ranchers
Eddie Ann and Dan Philippine II don't
own all the land on their three and a
half thousand acre ranch some of it they
leased from a division of the federal
government known as the Bureau of Land
Management or the BLM the agency
controls a total of 155 million acres in
the u.s. that is set aside for livestock
raising private ranchers like the
Philippine ease get to use this land to
feed their cattle but they also pay for
this rate when a ranch is purchased part
of the purchase price is based on
ability to graze on your own your BLM
grazing rights Pete and Lynn Tamara are
neighbors of the Philippine ease they
also lease land from the Bureau of Land
Management the BLM permit is its
property it's a it's a property right
when it is closed off when part of your
grazing permit is taken away from you it
decreases the value of your ranch in
2014 the Bureau of Land Management made
a decision to prohibit grazing on some
of the land use by the Tamera's and the
Philippine 'yes why because the agency
was concerned about a drought so we had
to remove all of our cattle from those
two allotments and find alternative
pasture for him we sold about 400
between four and five hundred head of
cattle because we couldn't couldn't keep
them mister devastating
to have the cattle up on the hill it's
the difference between surviving and not
surviving because right here on the flat
you can't feed cattle all summer long
you just don't have enough hay you can't
afford to do it
Raul Morales is the deputy state
director of the Bureau of Land
Management
he said the agency had no choice but to
revoke the grazing rights on its land
Nevada has actually been in drops eight
of the last ten years
and the last four years we've had four
years of consistent dropped and this
year being the worst droughts but the
Tamera's in the philippine e's say that
the grazing lands they are using are
actually in good shape they've been
inviting outside observers in to see
them for themselves one visitor snapped
a picture of lands so healthy the grass
had risen 21 inches high raul Morales
says the reason the land is returning to
health is because of the temporary ban
on grazing but we manage those lands for
their health and recognizing during
drought situations we have to be
responsible for the management and work
with our partners in achieving a success
the Tamera's say it's the ranchers who
possess the expertise and incentive to
best care for the land during a drought
we realized that if we overuse it or
abuse the land this year next year
there's going to be any 4-h out there
for our cattle so we we know how to take
care of it and we do we've done it all
our life I mean you just don't come into
a ranch and say well I'm gonna run it
they are taking your property your
private bought and paid for property the
Tamera's and the Filipinos have filed a
lawsuit to return their cattle to the
land and they're in talks with the
Bureau of Land Management to work out a
deal but this process is dragging on
with no clear timetable meanwhile their
businesses are suffering well if we can
win it'll be okay we can't win I don't
know what we do if we get unfavorable
decisions that the future doesn't look
very bright so I don't know we won't be
in business we'll have to sell our cows
I mean you can pay a lawyer $300 an hour
$250 an hour
and you're you've taken it to the to the
BLM land board which is its feel and
employees BLM lawyers BLM judges so
you're you're fighting with your dollar
and then you're paying for them to run
you out of business
you